[Music]
we live in an increasingly cynical age
where a romantic love has been distilled
into algorithms of data where love is
reduced to nothing more than the
neurotransmitter dopamine biochemically
no different than addiction to cocaine
imagine that's right
the romantic passion of the lover
reduced to a coke head on a coke binge
there's something kind of cynical about
this resignation about letting go of
that ecstasy of love that inspired you
know the Romeo and Juliet story you know
the archetype of finding the one that is
as God you know these encounters with
these divine beings to put the lover on
a pedestal and lose oneself in an
ecstatic sexual worship you know a
stage-managed resurrection and
apotheosis I mean that's the kind of
love that I still crave that's why we
still go to the movies and remove to
tears by moments of tenderness and
beauty those in-between times you know
those moments of pillow talk and
intersubjectivity those moments of the
happy sad where your lover looks at you
and you look at them and you see
yourself being seen by them these
moments these exchanges these intimacy's
these moments of consummation I think
they still live in the back of our
cyclist intake hinting at greater
greater intimacy's and greater exchanges
and deeper higher fidelities of nuance
and intimacy with the other and that
promise
I think keeps us searching and keeps us
chronically dissatisfied we will not
settle
we will not we will not let go of that
romantic dream that of that that moment
those goosebumps that tenderness hey
guys be sure to check out the dictionary
of obscure sorrows which is literally a
compendium of words we've never heard
before used to describe elusive feelings
that we can barely ever articulate but
we will surely recognize check it out